[Musique]
les chers compatriotes cheveux que
l'once est confondre assistance avec
solidarité
si je suis élu président de la
république je vous montrais les
indemnités des chômeurs mais en
contrepartie je demanderai qu aucun
chômeur ne puisse refuser plus de deux
offres d'emploi correspondant à ses
capacités professionnelles
si je suis président de la république je
dirais à tous les jeunes des quartiers
difficiles que je vais d aider à trouver
une formation et un emploi mais je leur
dis que nul ne peut demander d'être
aidés par la société cim est pas capable
de se donner par lui-même le mal
nécessaire pour s'en sortir
[Musique]
je sais le malaise des enseignants qui
sont dévouées admirable de compétences
et d'engagement je connais le malaise de
l'école mon objectif pour l'école de la
république est simple je veux
l'excellence je veux qu qu'un jeune
puisse sortir sans savoir lire écrire
compter sans avoir une qualification qui
lui permettent dans la société de
connaissance qui est celle du xxième
siècle de se faire une place
je veux une école du respect je veux une
école de la transmission la transmission
nous valeur le travail le mérite
l'autorité le respect je veux pour
chacun d'entre vous la liberté de
choisir son école que cela soit l'école
publique où l'école privée je veux moins
d'élèves dans les classes difficiles
je veux une meilleure rémunération pour
les enseignants qui prennent la
responsabilité d'assumer l'enseignement
dans des milieux défavorisés où c'est
plus difficile où il faut s'engager
davantage
[Musique]
je veux dire aux français que je
garantirai votre santé je garantirai la
pérennité de vos retraites
je garantirai l'assurance maladie mais
je veux également dire que je vais
lutter contre la fraude contre le
gaspillage public le personnel
hospitalier mérite mieux que d'avoir été
totalement désorganisé par les 35 qui
ont mis la pagaille à l'hôpital plus
encore que dans l'ensemble des autres
services publics
[Musique]
je veux engager une très grande ambition
au service de nos compatriotes les plus
âgés ceux qui sont dépendants
ce qui se retrouve frappé par ce drame
qu'est la maladie d'alzheimer je veux
que chacun puisse se dire qu'il pourra
terminer ses jours chez lui ou dans un
établissement digne et cheveux blancs
c'est beaucoup d'expérience beaucoup de
sagesse
c'est aussi beaucoup de courtoisie et
beaucoup de respect dans une société qui
en a besoin
et puis vous avez bien mérité de vous
reposer vous détendre si vous saviez
comme j'aurais envie jakarta la table
bien sûr
[Musique]
je veux vous parler de vos retraites
nous allons vivre plus longtemps si nous
ne cotisons pas puni temps il n'y a
aucune chance que nous assurions
financement de nos retraites ce qui vous
propose de revenir sur les lois filles
sont ceux qui sont incapables de vous
garantir la pérennité au régime de
retraite et en même temps je sais qu'il
ya beaucoup de petites retraites
les artisans les agriculteurs les
commerçants trois millions d'entre vous
qui ont une retraite inférieure au
minimum vieillesse
j'augmenterais de 25% portrait comment
le financer
eh bien je ferai la réforme des régimes
spéciaux mais je poserai également la
question des pensions de réversion je
pense à toutes les veuves qui n'ont
jusqu'à présent que 54 % de la retraite
de leur mari défunt je veux porter un
minimum de 60%
cette pension de réversion et jeudi
également qu'à ceux qui veulent partir
plus tard parce qu'il se sent en pleine
forme et parce qu'ils veulent continuer
de travailler que je leur donnerai le
droit de continuer à travailler
[Musique]
la personne qui a un handicap par sa
spontanéité par sa gentillesse par son
désir de donner d'aller vers les autres
elle est importante pour notre société
le handicap
mes chers compatriotes ça peut frapper
tout le monde à n'importe quel moment
dans n'importe quelles conditions
le handicap c'est la maladie qui s'abat
où c'est l'accident qui brise une vire
même temps qu'un corps et handicapés ne
dort pas être regardés comme des gens
différents et handicapées seynod le
handicap porte des valeurs de courage de
dignité de soif de vivre qui sont utiles
pour la société française
beaucoup de français réclament la
solidarité moi je pense que s'il en est
une catégorie qui en a besoin c'est bien
celle des handicapés de leur famille je
répondrai à nos aspirations
je ne veux pas qu'on les laisse de côté
la façon dont on prête des handicapés
dans un pays
c'est la façon dont on respecte la
société et sopi
[Musique]